how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
black widow
is right around the corner now i've been
fortunate enough to have seen black
widow a few times now thank you to
disney and marvel for sending me the
pre-screener ahead of time and this is
going to be my spoiler-free review i
will talk in depth about a few things
but i will not spoil any part of the
movie however
i am going to do my best to be
completely honest about this film
because i know a lot of people have been
wondering about it and i've been getting
a lot of questions about it now right
off the bat i will say
black widow is a good movie but whether
or not you will find this movie a good
or great movie
kind of depends i went into this movie
kind of thinking it was going to be
a little bit different than it actually
was and i kind of did an experiment a
couple of weeks ago i got to pre-screen
it and i watched it twice
and then last night i watched it again
in preparation for my review and i can
tell you that each experience was a
little bit different and i'll tell you
how to get the most out of the black
widow film in this video
but before we get started please allow
me to thank our sponsors for today's
video skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes for creative and
curious people
i've used skillshare to take classes
about youtube about photoshop about
final cut pro and other editing software
and if you're looking to do youtube
yourself it's a great place to learn
everything you need to know
i also use it personally i used to use
it to learn how to play guitar better
and now i'm using it to try and learn
how to sing better if you are looking
for a place to explore your creativity
or to simply get better at things
skillshare is the perfect place to learn
all of these things
and the great news is is that the first
thousand of my subscribers to click on
the link in my description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium so you
can explore your creativity and if
you're not one of the first thousands
don't worry it's only ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription so
it's very very affordable
just click the link in the description
down below to get started so again
right off the bat black widow is a good
movie i think a lot of fans are going to
be very pleased with this film
i did enjoy it more each time i watched
it and i believe that the reason for
that
is is because i knew what i was going to
be watching and i'm going to start with
some of the negative sides and end with
some of the positive sides because
i think overall this movie did what it
was supposed to do it said farewell to
natasha and then it brought in
a new character that is going to be a
part of the mcu hopefully for a pretty
long time and that of course
is yelena bulova now right off the bat
one thing i will say about the movie is
that i did expect there to be
a lot more about the red room and i
think a lot of fans are expecting this
and i just kind of want to set
expectations for it right now you don't
get a whole lot of the red room
yes the movie is about taking down the
red room and taking down dracov which
we've seen in the trailers by now but as
far as
what happens to natasha in the red room
all of the extensive training that she
gets in the red room all of the
extensive training that yelena gets in
the red room you don't get too much of
that
and to me going into this movie i
thought i was going to get a lot of that
i thought i was going to see
how black widow became black widow
now they do address this they don't just
say oh she was in the red room and she
became a black widow and now here she is
she's an avenger and she's trying to
right some wrongs before you know she
dies in avengers inn game
it's definitely a lot more than that and
this movie does give you a lot of
answers which i did really enjoy
and i also think that we deserve to know
about black widow but as far as natasha
romanov
as a teenager training in the red room
learning hand-to-hand combat learning
how to shoot weapons
that's not really what this movie is
about and i think going into it i kind
of thought that
that's what it would be about for a good
amount of time but instead what this
movie does is they
address what happened in the past tell
you a little bit about it but then
address what is happening
in the future it is very much a present
story
taking on things that are happening
during the present time which is really
between
captain america civil war and avengers
infinity war tying it into the past and
making sure those
loose ends from the past are tied up now
they do a good job
of connecting the past to the future and
there is some really good scenes
especially in the very beginning of
natasha and elena as children we've seen
this in the trailers and they do a good
job
of kind of making a very good opening
scene out of this however something that
they do in this film that marvel has
never done before
is they kind of have a montage of
opening credits in the beginning that's
a bunch of pictures of what happened to
natasha and elena as kids and that's
kind of where we get the red room stuff
kind of little clips some pictures with
music playing over it and originally
when i watched
it i thought well i wanted more than
that but if you consider what the movie
is about
her and her sister and her so-called
family trying to do things right in the
present time it actually makes sense
that they don't dwell too much about the
past
i will say that the movie does try to
cram a lot within about two hours and 10
minutes and that's because there is a
lot of layers to this movie there's the
family aspect there's the getting rid of
the red room there's the fact that
natasha is no longer a black widow she
is now an avenger then you have the
whole family aspect of them coming
together again
many years down the line alexis
shostakov aka the red guardian
melina vostikov who is pretty much
natasha and jelena's mother figure and
of course
elena balova natasha's sister a lot of
great scenes come from
this so called family honestly a lot of
the really great scenes of the movie
come from david arbour's alexi shostakov
aka the red guardian and
elena bulova played by florence pugh
these characters are absolutely
fantastic
and they make the movie really really
good scarlett johansson of course
is amazing as black widow we have seen
her over 10 years now play black widow
she does an incredible job and you can
tell that this film meant a lot to her
but this film is about her family and
that's one of the reasons that it does
get kind of sentimental which i do enjoy
i enjoy the sentimental parts there are
some touching moments i just wish we had
more time
to further explore them i felt like some
of the sentimental scenes were a bit
rushed
but i think a lot of people may actually
like that they don't dwell too much on
them and the movie actually does an
insanely good job
at putting touching moments into the
movie but then also putting some comedic
moments into it and keeping the whole
seriousness of the actual spy movie and
taking down the red room because that's
a good
majority of what the movie is about
family coming together
the only family that these particular
people have ever really had
coming together to take down a horrible
horrible program and if you go into the
movie thinking that
that's what it's about it's a spy movie
it's about natasha and her family trying
to take down the red room you're going
to really enjoy this film but don't
expect a whole lot of black widow
training in the red room because that
might let you down
however there are a lot of really great
things about this movie i for one really
enjoyed the hand-to-hand combat aspect
there are a lot of
really really great fights and they
introduced one of the greatest villains
we've seen on screen so far
taskmaster his scenes are fantastic
and it's super cool to see the fight
between taskmaster and black widow
taskmaster and yelena taskmaster
and red guardian and of course everybody
is sitting there wondering
who exactly is taskmaster they want to
know who the identity is which of course
i am not going to reveal at this time
because that would be a huge spoiler
and i gotta give credit to marvel i
didn't really see this one coming
granted i didn't really state too much
who i thought it was but it definitely
wasn't who i thought it was
and you know it's my job to think about
this stuff so i have thought about it
and uh this person's name didn't really
cross my mind
but they did this in a way that was
actually very very fitting to the story
it wasn't some random unnecessary
character thrown into the mix
it made a lot of sense wise now all the
action
is pretty much really good the movie is
packed with action there are some slow
parts where they talk about you know
their family and they get their deep
moments but they're usually interrupted
by something
overall the action scenes together are
really good the final action scenes are
insanely good as well there is
one part where the cgi isn't fantastic
but it's for like
three seconds and it doesn't really
matter overall i enjoyed it i enjoyed
the movie a lot and i enjoyed
how it ended it ended with a lot of
possibility for elena bulova
and some other pretty cool characters as
well that i hope we see down the road
now there is a post credit scene to this
film and i personally enjoyed it it gave
us kind of two different levels
and one of those levels is something
that i know fans are going to be super
excited about so overall with the right
expectations
i really enjoyed black widow i give it a
solid b
b plus it was a great movie it wasn't
the greatest marvel movie of all time it
wasn't avengers end game avengers
infinity war but as i stated before
nothing really will be for a film about
black widow
tying up her loose ends before she goes
on to die in avengers in-game
it's a good movie and i think fans are
really really going to enjoy it as long
as they don't expect
too much about her training in the red
room because again for me i thought that
that's what we really were going to see
which it doesn't focus too much on but
if you go in excited to watch a movie
about black widow and her family it's
going to be a good movie for you and
you're going to enjoy it and overall i
think it's a great movie to say goodbye
to black widow so let me know in the
comments down below how excited you are
for black widow to finally come out in a
little bit over a week now
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof